critics say you can't do this your
answer to them is we've done it if
you're doing something new then people
are going to criticize you rise and
shine it's in spresso time good morning
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded onto the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message ignore the critics over
to you Elon Musk there are people who've
been in the rocketry business for
decades yeah who say about you that you
don't know what you don't know well I
suppose that's true of anyone how can
anyone know what they don't know critics
say you can't do this your answer to
them is we've done it he's done it in
partnership with NASA which has given
SpaceX technical advice and a contract
worth up to 1.6 billion dollars
mostly for 12 cargo flights to the space
station but SpaceX's lack of experience
bothers some NASA legends like Apollo
astronauts Neil Armstrong and Gene
Cernan they've testified to Congress
that the Obama administration's drive to
commercialize space could compromise
safety and eventually cost the taxpayers
now it's a time to overrule this
administration's pledge to mediocrity
you know there are American heroes who
don't like this idea Neil Armstrong Gene
Cernan have both testified against
commercial spaceflight in the way that
you're developing it and I wonder what
you think of that I was very sad to see
that because those guys are yeah
you know those guys here's mine so it's
really tough you know I wish they would
come and visit and and see the hardware
that we're doing here and I think that
would change their mind they inspired
you to do this didn't they yes
and to see them casting stones in your
direction it's difficult
did you expect them to cheer you on so
they hoping it would what are you trying
to prove to them what I'm trying to do
is to make a significant difference in
in space flight and and and help make
space flight accessible to to almost
anyone I would vote for as much support
in that direction as we as we can
receive if you're doing something new
then people are going to criticize you
that's just a game there are so many
people who love the way that things are
currently being done there's so many
people whose careers whose lives are
attached to the status quo and as soon
as you come in and propose a new way of
doing something say I'm gonna break the
mold on this you're gonna have a lot of
people who naturally are just against
that because it it's part of their
identity they like the old way of doing
things they don't want to see you be
successful in a new way that's part of
every entrepreneurial venture every
entrepreneur who stepped out and said
I'm gonna go off and do something crazy
and different had a ton of people who
criticize them and sometimes that the
criticism comes from people that you
love it might be your mom it might be
your dad it might be your brother sister
friends and a lot of that is out of love
because they see successes as one path
maybe your mom had success by being a
doctor and so she sees success as being
a doctor and that's what she wants for
you and you going off into this crazy
improving thing seems risky and so her
negativity towards you is based off of
just how she sees success and it comes
from a place of loving no it doesn't you
gonna listen to that you don't want to
be a doctor like care you want to do
your own path but understanding that it
comes from a source of love there'll be
a lot of people though who don't come
from voice of love right who just want
to tear you down I call them the little
man it's the person who points out all
the holes in your dreams all the
problems in your plan and tell you that
you're not good enough and you're never
gonna make it a lot of times it's
because they took their shot they tried
to do something and it didn't work out
and so now nobody around that can be
successful or because they have a lot
invested in the status quo and they
don't want to think outside the box they
don't want to go to this new idea and so
when they're saying that a lot of times
the critics a negative the negative
people around you they may not
understand the industry but sometimes
they do
sometimes they're the experts in your
industry the concept of little man
came from when I made a video on my
channel it was a six-and-a-half minute
long video and I showed it to somebody
who was in the industry and he said no
video on YouTube should be six and a
half minutes long it should only be two
to three minutes you don't understand
the internet you don't understand how
things are going
this video is wrong and a younger less
confident version of myself might have
accepted that and made changes to it
what I looked at the video and I said
you know what this guy may be right but
I like this video you know it moved me
now most of my videos are ten plus
minutes long but this one was
six-and-a-half minutes and I said you
know what I'm just gonna post it and if
it fails then fine it's my failure I'll
own that loss but if I don't post it
because of his opinion that's a big
problem then I could live with that
regret for the rest of my life
and so I posted it and it quickly became
the best video on my channel we had a
hundred thousand views in the first
month it was my first video two million
views and now it's two million plus
views on the channel if I listen to the
expert I would have made that video and
that's part of what we do as
entrepreneurs you want to use expert
opinions in the people around you as as
a counselor or not a jailer where so
many times somebody else's opinion
prevents you from doing the thing that
you want to do if it feels right if it
feels like you just need to know like
sometimes it's just I might mess up I
might make the biggest mistake in the
world but I just need to know for myself
I don't want to live with the regret for
the rest of my life and just do it
expect the haters expect a little man
expected criticism if you have no little
man in your life then you're not doing
anything big enough now I've got a
special bonus clip for you but before
getting to it my question of the day is
who is the biggest little man or hater
or critic in your life who is that leave
them comments below I'm really curious
to find out thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso and enjoy the bonus
more spray so keep me go
being a child star as they call it or or
having worked as a miner you do you do
sort of have to be aware of the of the
kind of trajectory and also kind of
aware the that people are viewing your
performances through a very different
lens it's I saw a really interesting
article yesterday that you know people
had seen the trailer and they're like oh
you know Emma Watson like scandalous
like really trying to push the push the
envelope and step away from Hermione
Harry Potter and whatever else and it's
like I'm just kissing someone you know
and it's kind of like this huge deal and
it's so you know you're aware of that
but you also I don't like to try and let
all of that noise affect my choices and
my decisions because ultimately if you
live like that then you you know I think
it would it would close me off to a lot
of opportunities and and experiences the
New York Post has declared a bit of a
print jihad against Quentin Tarantino
apparently the data is that is that
concern you at all is that a badge of
honor metal in New York Post I mean they
can say whatever they whatever they've
made it they they've made it pretty
clear where they're coming from it is
yes all right you know so I they can say
they can say whatever they wanted like I
said long as I don't Google my name then
it's just your mentioning it right now
and I can swap it off if I make myself
read every single article then I'll get
part second what do you think of the
tractors that attempt to claim your
sound is too mainstream mm I mean
everyone has their as their own music
tastes I don't know I haven't changed my
sound a bit from when I started to now
in order to please the mainstream I've
always been doing the music I'm doing
now I always stay true to myself and you
know like the music has become more
popular and you know the mainstream has
opened
it's a lot of more instrumental tracks
and stuff like that and I've always been
interesting and doing these kind of like
really melodic uplifting tracks so I you
know when I I just kind of laugh when I
see people you know you know telling me
I've sold out or something like that cuz
I haven't thought I'm changed anything
you know so I was wondering do you find
it bothersome little when people say
things like that because as you said
you've been creating the same sound for
a very long time so you haven't changed
the only thing that has changed as more
people have discovered you so does it
feel weird to have people essentially
hating on your success yeah I mean it's
in the beginning you've bothered me
because you're like oh yeah I want to
tell this person that it's not like that
you know like or you know kinda like are
you stupid just look at you know my
music then I look at my music now but
then you know there I used to notice the
better things go like everyone said the
more haters you get like by default and
I mean you can't say it to everyone and
I mean it doesn't really matter anyway
so right now I just felt like brush it
off and don't really care that much but
obviously it's it's it's an annoying
thing there's just something you have to
overlook raise your standard Apple at
the cool it's core value is that people
passion not one drop of my self-worth
depends on your it's something to me I
don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten most a success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link in description for details